hey everyone we are back we are now with
Jane McHale hi hey thank you coming on
my pleasure
yes I'm so excited so Jane founded wired
25 years ago sold it off now now start a
new life
yeah year ago and I love getting her
emails thank you so much I'm sending up
yeah so co dot life is gonna be in the
bio as well check it out okay tell us a
bit like what was this transition like
nah wired neo life
ah yes well what you're missing is the
20 years in between which I'm happy you
know concatenate if you want but wire
definitely was the precursor to neo life
even though as I said a lot of time
passed in between so we saw a bunch of
conditions back in the late 80s that
made us realize that the world was
getting ready to go kaboom and it was
going to be driven by the digitization
of all these different data types and
the creation of networks that were going
to connect all the computers together so
it was you know first of all it was
multimedia and then it was networking
and so you know we were writing about
the technologies for other people
developing technologies and researchers
but you know we came to San Francisco
and we met these crazy engineers and we
went to Macworld and we went to like the
Grateful Dead show and all the sudden
was like wow these people are amazing I
mean things these people have a mission
you know and they are like super
passionate about giving tools to
creative people about unlocking all
sorts of educational opportunities about
you know democratizing our our world
about you know access and openness and
innovation and you know open source
ideas and private and it's just this
whole kind of all the stuff that came
along with you know unlocking these
opportunities you know the social and
the political side of it
and then the whole lifestyle aspect of
it too and so you know we came back
we're living in Amsterdam so we came
back to Amsterdam and of course a little
scene we had going on there was you know
it was sort of you know super geeky
researchers and then cyber punts so we
had you know the rave scene in London
and that was spilling over to Amsterdam
and and so anyway this was a very rich
stew out of which wired was born and we
moved to San Francisco to be you know
it's in Rome at the height of the Roman
Empire yes and that was kind of an
amazing thing and we coined this phrase
digital revolution and so we put signs
up this color on on buses streaking
through you know wintry scenes in New
York and Boston and San Francisco and
said finally you know a magazine for the
digital age and what ensued was you know
this amazing ride and you know the
people who were involved in the in the
creation of Wired the first five years
of Wired have gone on to do
extraordinary things I mean if you were
to like do of the centerfold of a
magazine and it would start with the
team at Wired and then just all the
companies and ideas the technologies
that have spun out of that in movies and
books and you know babies and you know
that whole thing it'd be really rich but
we sold the company the wired mafia the
wired mafia exactly we sold the company
had two babies you know we did the whole
Jet Set thing for a while and you know
did some startup investments and
and so forth and you know basically got
out of media and so I was busy doing a
lot of philanthropic work and you know
the art world and digital divide issues
and education I got involved with UC
Berkeley but anyway Louis invested was
Chocolate Factory so I found myself
running a Chocolate Factory at one point
and learned a lot about food and
specifically like the theobromine
molecule which is extraordinary it's
just like caffeine except for one hydro
carbon atom different so if you looked
at a diagram you know they are by
definition design it's like designer
drugs you just go oh we'll take that one
thing you know that makes your soft
muscle tissues sort of you know dilate
it makes everything sort of crispy and
jittery I will just get rid of that so
you get the stimulation of a central
nervous system stimulant but then you
get the softness of tissue relaxant and
I started thinking about the health
benefits right and the research on
chocolate factory well because the
health benefits of dark chocolate what
is it called in the molecule the
molecules called theobromine Theobroma
yes and that's found in cacao cacao
exactly so theobromine actually means
food of the gods
right those aspects you know they had it
off at Montezuma he had it figured out
Wow and the Europeans by the time the
cacao made it to Europe it was only
reserved for the Monarchs for a long
time ya know it's a very special drug
anyway so that drug got me thinking
about
science and the power of food to impact
our health and then I started looking at
the health epidemic in our country yeah
you know whether it's the Alzheimer's
epidemic or whether it's obesity opioid
you know all of these things the huge
costs the extraordinary waste and
inefficiency not to mention the like
legal and social impacts of all of this
and all this I mean I was like you know
there must be technological solutions
and it kind of brought me full circle
and so I started going to conferences
and meeting people who are designing
digital tools to solve health problems
solve biological problems and all of a
sudden it was like the next coming of a
digital revolution yeah the obvious next
wave of the digital revolution and so I
thought this is like a neo biological
revolution so the definition of the neo
biological revolution is you know this
explosion of tools driven by engineering
and computer science that are allowing
us to alter our own biology yep and then
I thought so what's my role in that and
you know I just I met extraordinary
people and there's incredible stories
you know they're so passionate they're
so driven it's such a relief after being
in Silicon Valley for the last I don't
know 15 years where it's all about
advertising you know they're just like
there's something bigger than that
yeah that these brilliant people should
be focused on and when
comes to health when it comes to you
know wellness when it comes to longevity
when it comes to life and death that's a
motivator and so I have found the most
extraordinary people doing the most
outrageous important work you know and
it has implications not just for humans
but you know for animals for plants for
the way we inhabit the planet that we're
on and implications for the next planet
we we go colonize or inhabit or explore
let's start with explore yeah yes so so
then this really moving to Silicon
Valley and having this vision of like
okay there's a bunch of luminaries here
it's really great to be here what's this
next thing because it's not just limited
to this advertising and apps and this
whole economy of just software but
there's more and so then design
discovering this community of biology in
these tool sets that the code of life
gives us to alter both our own health
with epidemics like obesity as well as
potential augmentations to end suffering
in the human disease and then being like
okay I want to start a publication that
highlights all these brilliant people in
this industry that's going to that is
already kind of the next big thing and
it's only getting bigger and you're only
highlighting more and more
what-what-what-what publishing
publishing number where you published a
60 no no not 60 out I think it was
either 58 or 59 okay yeah is it Wii is
it weekly yes we do it weekly once a
week at this point
and so we do original stories that we
commissioned and so we have a few people
will pitch us ideas we've got a coterie
of writers that are pitching us ideas
but for the most part we're still
initiating the story and so you know we
find something we want to write about we
find a writer that we think can do it
sometimes we write it ourselves and then
yeah we get like a photographer and
illustrator and you know do a full
journalistic you know approach to the
story which you know people like Oh your
blog is so great it's a please don't
call it a blog you know it's like I'm a
publisher you know I'm like an
old-school publisher I believe in
getting the facts straight
I believe in punctuation I believe in
grammar you know and and I think there's
still a place in the world for that and
so no I you know so what we're doing
right now it's looking for science
communicators you know and you know this
people who can talk about science but
who can they're not science explainers
you know because that's observatory
tower it's storytelling you know it's
what's the hook I have a friend a
neuroscientist and he's you know sent me
a couple papers and I'm busy and I'm
flying and talking and publishing him
it's like dude tell me what's important
about this yeah you know and that's
where the story starts and so for so
many scientists that's where it ends my
work is already done here and it's like
no you you're just starting
and I want to hear about all the
failures that led up to that one result
or the day when you finally kick the
whole thing over and that's when they
you know uh Hamid
you know the accident that led to all up
notes or your elevator pitch or your
elevator pitch I like that one yeah
that's um LuAnn my favorites because it
forces them to condense into what's most
relatable yeah yeah that's elevator
pitch to a five-year-old that also has a
billion dollars that's looking in so I
don't want that I actually don't want
that because I think there's plenty of
people who do that you know the
mainstream media whether that's online
or in print or whatever are doing that
and you know I see this big sweet spot
for neo life which is in between the
mainstream media who you know as long as
a five-year-old can follow it and that's
fine and it's gonna be pretty
superficial and we're just going to find
that little hook because we know you're
gonna click right through to the next
story in a split second the business
press you know we were covering this
as a business story so it's about you
know how much money you've raised and
what your your valuation is and what
your quarterly earnings are and you know
all that kind of stuff which is
important but not really we're we're the
sweet spot of the story usually is and
the more scientific and technical
publications which is where their papers
are being published
so in between is this sweet spot so I'm
not writing for a five-year-old I'm
running for a high school senior yeah
you know what I mean it's I'm ready for
the person who wants a little more
detail you know I just I just want to go
a little bit deeper I want to understand
things a little bit more and scientists
really have a hard time because they'll
either write for a scientific audience
or they'll talk to a five-year-old but
something in between so that's what
we're sort of you know we're working
with scientists and we're working with
writers who who get that spot that we're
going for and I typically over
exaggerate by saying the five-year-old
cuz our show does a lot of the
communicating some more like of a high
school level as well where we take the
technical brains such amazing to diverse
people but then we try and figure out
how to make it relatable to either high
school or young adults yeah and
especially ones that might not be
familiar with what RNA is because this
is it's actually tough stuff right and
it's not that relatable because it's not
really visible or tangible and so that
that's another tough thing is there's so
many technologies in biology especially
that are not really visible or tangible
and so because of that then people are
like alright now we have to really do a
good job at storytelling to get it into
people yeah ok so now that's judging
right so through high schools you start
your first you know biology class is
sort of like 5th grade or something when
puberty begins so it's like oh we better
get these kids primed for this mm-hmm
and then they come back in like eighth
or ninth grade
now once you've had a little bit more
math you know and they try and approach
it again but then you have to go off and
learn chemistry and physics you know
before you come back to biology and even
then so now you're graduated from high
school and you know this much yeah you
know and everything that you thought you
knew when you graduated from high school
even if it was only five years ago you
know it's like completely obsolete
yeah by the new stuff that's coming in I
mean it's what we're understanding what
we've understood in the last five years
about brain mapping you know about the
genome about the epigenome you know the
transcriptome you know the proteomics I
mean all this stuff is just we're going
wait okay so I thought I had this
picture yeah let me back up a minute you
know now let me back up again now let's
layer in the microbiome no let's layer
in all this other stuff yeah so yeah I
mean you know even people in the field
can't keep up with other disciplines you
know if they're neuroscientists they
know neuroscience and they know it
deeply you know and if you want to talk
to them about nutrition they're like
that I don't know anything about
nutrition I was like actually the link
between the gut and the brain is really
intense right there's like as many
neurotransmitters in your gut as there
are in your brain there's dopamine and
serotonin you know and there's this
pathway and you know it could there
could be bacterial components to
Parkinson's disease and Alzheimer's you
know and so it's kind of not an option
to not know about the microbots yeah you
know so that's what I'm really
interested in is like all of these
disciplines are deep and I will never be
a specialist in any one of like what I
don't pretend to be like wise but what
I'm looking for are you know the the
people the scientists that see
opportunities in different fields and if
we can be a part of helping people see
that helping them discover something
that they have an aha moment in their
then my date is good mm-hmm
and making these novel connections
across maybe the gut to the brain how
much free will you actually have over
what you choose all these different
things that are workable maybe another
one about if you are about to have a an
environmental impact on you that's
gearing you towards obesity is there a
way to counter that and is a can we can
we get to a point where this has become
being an actual integrated part of our
culture and objectively you know who
wants to be obese you really want to be
obese no well then can we make it almost
objectively true that nobody wants to be
obese and then can we work on that
together can all 7 to 1/2 billion people
sign off on that that would be great and
so that way maybe we can actually open
up these data sets to be more horizontal
so that way we can actually run the
machine learning across them and you can
be safe that your data is not being
infringed upon by Kamber gentleman
so so yeah so this seems to be a passion
of yours over this last you're a huge
passion a science communicator you're
like all over biotech right now
oh yeah no I wake up every morning and
it's you know and this is this is what
you wait for in life you know for
lightning to strike twice because you
know I had that with wired you know I
woke up every morning it was like I just
went looking for evidence of the bite of
the sorry digital revolution yeah you
know it was just so much fun and whether
it was you know accumulating that
evidence for editorial purposes or
whether it was accumulating that
evidence Cadell to go explain to an
advertiser why they needed to advertise
with us yeah you know it was like for me
it was all the same I didn't care I was
like I was on a mission yeah yeah and
and that's a privilege it is it to be
able to find something like you have you
know that really gets your goose
you know steamin get you smoking every
morning I mean it's like what it should
also be it should be you should require
a little bit of alignment and hard work
to figure out what that thing is for the
child that brings them to fulfillment
but also it should be something that we
facilitate as a civilization to make it
easier for children and parents to find
that thing otherwise we end up we end up
in the world that we kind of observe
right now what is this 9:00 to 5:00
where people don't like their job this
is not the way that civilization should
be designed let's not even talk about
that 9:00 to 5:00 let's start with the
fact that we plonk a kid down in a chair
you know in first grade and we make that
kid sit in that chair for 12 years and
then they graduate and they go sit in
another chair for four years and then
they graduate and guess what now you get
to go sit in a [ __ ] chair in front of
a computer screen for the rest of your
life yeah you're an adult is it any
surprise my kids were like I don't
yeah I mean my son I adore him and he
loves what he's doing but you know he's
learning mechanical engineering by
sitting in a room listening to
professors talk at it instead of
actually tinkering with the technology
and being creative with it why can't we
get that lecture thing from video you
know where you can control it at your
own pace you can do it at your own time
you know and then have these communal
experiences on college campuses be all
about you know finding your cohort of
people whether they're a freshman or a
senior you know I need a designer I need
a computer scientists I need a you know
a big data person I need a you know
whatever let's pull this thing together
because our assignment is but you know
and it's like working across these
disciplines that needs to start young
you know and we have these great models
of it that have never infiltrated our
bigger systems and so they remain these
lovely little examples of what education
could be let me been talking about it
for 50 60 years Seymour Papert
was talking about this in the 60s and
70s we know this is how people work best
we know this is how they learn and you
know what here we are in the 21st
century it's 2018 and guess what we're
getting
gamification yeah that's the answer it's
like that's still not the answer I still
think there's a better way to do it and
we've had gamification became hella
distracting away from automation and AI
because if everyone's attention is now
off of automation in AI and it's focused
on playing the little lottery systems on
social media and their games we have a
huge problem because that is literally
drinking wine on the back of the plane
as the pilot had a heart attack and
nobody's sparking accelerating the front
to go try and pick up the controls and
go and land the plane so I'm very very
aware of what is coming if a parent is
birthing a child right now handing them
over an iPad
Charles playing with the iPad and then
all of a sudden the child's trying to
become an accountant or a lawyer or
service industry worker barista or
whatever
and then they're like wait what do you
mean the jobs not there for me anymore
what do you mean I was trained to do
this yeah but now we have this augmented
reality headset where you can actually
retrain yourself to have a different
position to have a different skill set
and you can collaborate with people in a
location agnosticism across the world on
a project using these augments reality
tools I hope we're there now my hope
biotech ends up taking a huge bet in
augmented reality because I think that
if people can collaborate across the
world on observing microbiome or
observing Mollet and molecule effect on
tumors there's so many cool ways for
them to collaborate in the biotech
industry how about you give us uh let's
let's wrap it up by asking you what is
one of the one of your most favorite
things that you're looking forward to in
the biotech explosion there's favorite
there's impactful
there's terrifying yes
you know there's like what could it be
the biggest effect on their health care
system there's like all of that but I
think if I just zeroed in on like
outrageous yeah I honestly think the
most outrageous thing coming is is in
the field of bringing that ban yeah and
being able to you know to actually see
inside the brain understand what's
happening in the brain and then train
the brain to direct signals as a form of
communication you know either
to communicate with another person or to
drive a machine interface yeah you know
it's you know mind control
it's like telekinetics it's you know all
that stuff's coming real now I mean it's
all exploding right now in there a laced
all of wisdom ever oh right Jack into
the matrix directly directly hmm yeah
we're we're yeah there's some really
interesting work that's being done
Buzzelli and yeah their escape glass
green and open water open water yeah
Justin yeah a she's on her yeah I know
she is I know we've been trying to nail
her down for the show she's like in New
York right now she's always and then
there's like neuro priming you know it's
like what can you do that to set your
brain up so that what you do for the
next 45 minutes with intention will be
moved into your neuronal path and guess
what one of the easiest things to do is
just to put your phone on silent and put
to the side exactly or let's start by
getting a good night sleep Singapore for
ya
yeah and eating a salad instead of a
burger running yeah there's so many
things okay quick quick on this let's
see if we can keep it quick
do you have any
concerns about genetic engineering
exacerbating wealth and quality and how
do you think we can maybe collaborate
with China and the rest of the world as
we get into the globalized world oh I
think we are headed right into some
really stormy waters yes you know I
think genetic editing whether for you
know it's one thing to say we can
prevent the transmission of Huntington's
disease or tay-sachs disease or
something like that
yeah and if we focused our attention
there and scored some big wins you know
and publicize those it could help lead
the way for the other stuff that comes
behind it you know when we rush to
designer babies in the headlines you
know that's really undermining you know
this this progressive work that has to
take place first yeah so you know
preventing Mendelian inheritance is step
one you know step two is you know sort
of tumors and and in vivo stuff like you
know you're already born and you have
this problem but we can use CRISPR some
other technologies to intervene in a way
that will you know fix your problem now
you know I think personally step three
is is food and if we can do things with
gene editing that will increase the
drought tolerance for instance or
increase crop yields so that farmers can
actually earn a living
I think these things have huge potential
to really transform massive percentage
of you know the population on the planet
if we can also do things that will lower
the impact of pesticides and fertilizers
on the planet
these are all really big wins and you
know yeah there's research happening in
all these other areas but I think from a
commercial standpoint and from a you
know sort of a strategic standpoint
those things make a lot of sense because
the rest of it the minute you get us
beyond that all the rest of it is wide
open to you know ethical moral religious
you know slippery slopes and I got to
say there are no easy answers to these
questions and I just that's why we ask
them yeah exactly I just hope that we
could be part of you know the the
archive of material that people can go
to when they are trying to understand
what these issues are you know with a
very progressive bent on you know I
believe in technology as a solution to
you know our problems and it's a way to
move forward so you know that's my yeah
that's my angle I'm pretty upfront about
it you know so you're gonna get a biased
opinion here but I honestly believe this
is the best thing for the planet and the
species yeah I I agree and we have you
listed those good steps I thought those
were great okay but it wasn't quick and
it's not an easy answer it's a tough
answer okay last question what is the
deepest emotion you've ever felt fear
what's what's cuz love love is it's all
of the spheres deep inside you know and
so if you can't get rid of that thing
deep inside then you've got room for the
biggest emotion but I think fear is the
deepest thing that got to root it out
Jane thank you so much for joining us
greatly appreciate it thank you all
right awesome